you
hi everyone is jariyama HS org and I
just got paired up playing a 15-2 game
against hot sir 8000
who says have fun and good luck always
should I wish a have fun I have a friend
who said never never to wish your
opponent luck I'm the one who wants the
luck I better make a move let's let's
play the caro-kann a big fan
thank spot sir okay let's be consistent
here you play c6 to establish a strong
point on d5 you know I'm happy to see
Bishop d3 I feel like I really don't
have any issues facing this Bishop d3
line this exchange Carol I play from
time to time on the white end more
difficult line for me at least playing
on the black end is the payoff Botvinnik
with c4 unmoved four but okay here we
are
I just basically want to make sure I get
my light square bishop working so let's
first play Knight here intending Bishop
g4 which they could prevent with h3 that
is an idea taking measures to stop
Bishop f5 and Bishop to g4 now I could
play this right now Bishop g4 but is
there any rush mm-hmm Bishop g4 now
let's get a knight here and first if
they play each turn okay they're not
playing actually if they played h3 I
could consider an e5 strike so at that
mode they're stopping 'if I've delaying
the knight development so we could enter
hmm we could enter a line here where the
Queen comes out to be three if I play
Bishop g4 I'm not expecting a knight
move I'm expecting a counterpunch
against the weekend point b7 so
I think I'll need to take steps against
that like Bishop g4 Queen b3 Knight a5
Queen a4 check the bishop can return
Queen c2 Queen b6 a4 I'm still I'm gonna
shoot for that still
you know so this was my idea
Knight to a5 on a bishop check or queen
check return the Bishop to d7 them
they're happy to see them thinking here
yeah this line that I was citing before
with Queen a for Bishop d7 Queen c2
Queen b6 the idea with that is to
welcome a light square Bishop exchange
but they could maybe prevent that
altogether the Bishop b5 idea by playing
a form but that does we can be three and
so I might be able to make use of that
square however I'm not sure I could do
that right away because I'm Knight to b3
there's a counterpunching rook a3
slightly awkward potentially vulnerable
on a3 but mmm it's throwing a punch and
immediate punch at my knight on B 3 so
I'm not sure if that'll really amount to
anything so again this is the line I'm
talking about Queen a4 [ __ ] 57 Queen
back to C - Queen b6 a for that wolf
ok well pretty much have to return my
bishop now yeah and this is uh this is a
welcome sight because this is my bad guy
that Bishop for good Bishop exchange so
and I'm still on their queen so that's
why I'm blocking with this guy not not
this
so I guess queen a4 Bishop takes Bishop
is only helping me to develop I may
eventually force the issue queen a4 a6
or or maybe just get on with more
development b6
although hmm I may want to do something
about being in a pin right away
because I do have some fear of maybe
Knight f3 into e5 so I feel like white
is letting me off the hook a little bit
in a way by playing this move instead of
Queen a4 I'm not sure how great a
difference it is but I am satisfied with
how things have played out so far so
let's recapture and develop I'm still on
their queen so they have to react
nice e4 is a possibility probably a
pretty even position I'd say okay oh
let's see
that clean position potentially
vulnerable so too is my Queen position
I'm anticipating a ninety five move
eventually she'll need to find a new
home I don't think she'll have trouble
finding that though
Queen b5 is a nice forward reply 295
which makes life a little bit a little
bit difficult for white to Castle and I
think my Queen would be pretty safe on
b5 I'm just wondering some about playing
Queen b5 right now I'm leaning more
towards the most natural of moves
to develop my bishop but just taking
some pause here to work out maybe
there's a difference maybe it's more
important to place my queen on b5 first
no I don't think so let's get e6 in and
a bishop move of rook move I'm pretty
sure I know where my rooks place is
right now mm-hmm
I'd have to be a little bit cautious
here I think I might be leaning more
towards rook to c8 actually if I played
Bishop e7 95 Queen b5 a4 slightly
knowing Queen b6 if then b4 which is
really weakening to the c3 pawn I want
to be able to play it into c4 and have
coverage for my knight with a piece i
reck'n c8 would do that a bishop on e7
doesn't and he drawback with rook to c8
should I voluntarily go to b5 on
unprovoked here without 95 just to stop
castling be more than happy with the
Queen exchange hmm a slightly
interesting moment here
yeah I'm going to put the rook on the
half-open file you know make them sweat
a little bit right maybe they're nervous
the rook is opposite the or the queen is
opposite my rook that's putting the fear
right in them all right ninety five
ninety two castles three candidates here
for white they may want to play this to
immediately secure c4 this really isn't
much of an issue right now but given
time well I should say as with a little
bit more development on my end you know
once I have a bishop move in and I'm
castled I could think think about
playing b5 d4 I wonder maybe it would be
too soon instead of exceed I wonder
about b5 and on 95 I could play Queen b7
that would be a pretty nice spot for my
queen okay so they're going for that
Queen B 5a for maybe six if they do
before I have Knight c4 no worries Queen
b5 a for Knight d2 maybe I play knight
c6 and I think I have to go here let's
get there he's a pest on e5 for sure
probably the most annoying piece to me
is the knight on e5 to be expected it is
a piece on my side of the board ranks 5
6 7 and 8 so he has a lot of my
attention to watch over this
seven square with a piece otherwise he
might hit with the fork one day can that
castle how would they dislodge my Queen
position really like to see Knight to a3
that'll never happen I will gladly give
up the bishop damage the Queen side
structure holes everywhere c3 c4 on a
four where am I going with the Queen
I could actually consider moving forward
I think this is a good move on a4 I
think I will jump right in okay I think
I need to play bishop here Bishop d7 I'm
asking for trouble unprotected piece on
d6 discovery's Knight moves so I'm
thinking that Bishop e7 a4 Queen b6 if
b4 I could just play knight c6 in that
case no longer c4 cuz they have two
pieces on it I don't want to capture on
the square with the pawn I played my
rook on the C file to see the white
pawns directly not plug it up with a
pawn here all right let's go Bishop e7
expecting a form on a four I could try
to be a actually scratch that I could
still try to be a pest on beef before
isn't even a move a4 Queen here b4 is
not a move because I could take see I
knew there was a point behind rook c8
see what happens when you just play
logical moves and it just works out
these little details here there will be
no beef for a4 yeah I could see a4 and I
think a4 is a fine move
yeah it's desirable to get that rip on
working um yeah why not and I'll see a
great drawback in the weakness of b3 it
inconveniences one of my pieces I think
my queen stands much better on b5 then
she would on a6 if her intention is to
prevent Y from castling kingside
a4 queen a6 I think we might be having a
queen exchange I think this is a good
slight improvement over playing queen d3
right away to first play here and then
queen d3 or maybe even knight here
although I think it would be better to
have the Queen on d3 with the Queen's
exchanged a knight here he's a fantastic
piece tucked in right behind the d4 pawn
excellent prospects he'll have something
to say about these squares though
even on time if pots are 8,000 is a fan
of mine he'll it'll know that I'll
probably go into I'll be in time
pressure but we're even on the clock
call it eight minutes a piece I've got
the two second increment I really don't
know ooh I wonder if b4 is a move
because my coin is unprotected like if
b4 is played before a for like b4 Bishop
takes pawn queen here rook takes pawn a3
yikes are they gonna make me calculate
that stuff are they really going to play
before one nice thing is that I'm not
locked into taking if b4 right away I
could simply play knight c6 threatened a
knight exchange and then just play
against the backwards C pawn so if b4
isn't coming with some okay they want to
keep the Queen's on the board and castle
all right I think I just Castle No
a reason to play Knight c4 first let's
get castled see no reason to knock
castle alright I feel like my knight on
a five isn't really doing so much
anymore hmm I think I want to exchange
him also
if these Knights are exchanged that
means I have a jumping point for my
knight on f6 it's one way to look at it
this exchange influences the prospects
of my f6 Knight my King night there's a
I don't know what you might call its
some tension on this open square e for
if he ever moves 94 okay
Queen or rook Oh Queen definitely right
for two reasons one I'm threatening
Queen takes pawn and - I'm out of the
way of my beep on which is this next now
this is the next plan I'd like to
implement here a minority attack in time
D 5 a 5 V 4 be a little bit cautious
after b5 Knight here my queen is sort of
lacking squares so what are they going
to do Queen here is a plunder of the
night
and they're actually down on time love
it let them feel the pressure okay so
maybe just get the Queen off of the C
file only if you go here kind of working
yourself into a pen so maybe Queen d2
this seems too awkward like this rook
wants to be on e a pretty much wants to
stay here I think this is a fine idea
you know on the white end anticipating
this minority attack it'd probably be a
good idea to insert a four in reason
well if you're gonna play b5 and gun for
this you will have to first help my rook
out because you could take and then I'll
have to worry about maybe some rook
invasion along the a file before I get
to that b4 break I do have a loose piece
on e7 given time I'd like to get a
flight square in and I believe that this
will be the moment do so well this this
would be the flight scroll want for my
King g6 would weaken these two and this
guy'll probably give me a problem okay
in under developing move a little bit
curious to see that instead of Queen d2
um I wonder if I could play 94 right now
and try to do similar with my night I'd
like to have the nights exchanged
because it makes this plan a little bit
easier to get in and I could eventually
acquire a position where it's me who is
putting pressure on some weakness on
whites Queen side and they'll have to
defend they'll have to take up a
restricted posture so I really want to
play b5 but my fear is night 8 Knight to
e5 and I don't know that I really want
to play Queen here although that it's
not such a bad move
doubleday pawns well this open B file I
can't even make use of it because of
this guy I think earlier I should have
maybe given some consideration of b5 in
a 95 Queen d7 oh well 94 yeah let's
throw the knight in there on 95 I think
Queen b5 throw a punch
Pond maybe in some way there could be
some tactic against c3 I don't know
about that that I'd only ever see myself
getting a couple ponds with the
sacrifice on see-through 94 also makes
way for possibly Bishop f6 however he
could be kicked at any moment
f3 I would not mind seeing for one it
weakens their King along the diagonal
weakens them along the second-ranked
it also denies their Queen access to the
Kings side pawn cuts the White Queen off
and yeah f3 kicks the night to ask where
he may very well want to go to so hmm
let's play here I don't know that I
really yeah I will take b2 if they
played a four I would take here cuz then
this would collapse
okay I have the night under control is
uh I guess you'd say Queen side
movements moving towards the Queen side
moves are under control by my queen this
is I might return to this C 4 square why
not
I still wanna get this in it's taking
forever I want to get that in if I
reacted by playing Queen a6 instead of
Queen B 5
I believe white would play a 4 and I'm
really a long way off
ooh interesting
move you know I like that move that's a
good move okay let's let's take note of
something here I have v7 protected hmm I
like that move that's a good move its
defendant defending with my queen I feel
like I just want to play rook here not
missing anything just to cover this if a
queen trade happens then I take and I
don't have any worry of Knight d7 he
wasn't doing anything on their fate
anyhow I don't think it's so important
to watch over f7 more pieces were on
board and there were rooks breathing
down the e-file it's a different story
so I'm sacrifice here but all right got
a minute advantage all right
hmm time for a flight square let's sneak
that in the Queen moves I'm going to
challenge this Knight pretty much right
away I don't think there's any tricks
with the knight move and a Bishop takes
Knight removing the defender of the
Queen because I could always capture the
Queen and then take on d6 there wouldn't
be any good Bishop move from d6 to
capture a piece and give check or
anything like that there might be those
are things to think about those
Inbetweeners so
white still needs another flight square
I don't think that this is a good flight
square especially with the Queen's on
you really won't want to run towards the
center like this so the G pawn moves hmm
kind of tough for white not a good
shelter for the King h3 King on h2
that's a fine pocket a g2 h3 structure
they're really eating a lot of time here
I feel like if I avoided the Queen
exchange if I if I don't keep this
tension I feel like Queen a6 is met with
a six and then I have to worry of mmm I
have to worry of what I have to worry of
Queen b5 at some point and if I'm taking
the Queen they take and the rook is
brought to life so I feel like I need to
keep this how can I improve my position
further maybe I start with this mm-hmm
can I put a question to white with like
rook e8 and then a five maybe now it's
such a big fan of pulling my rook off of
this open file half open file king of
two leads me to believe that white is
really close to exchange in Queens like
kind of like all right I'll improve my
King slightly and then we're soon to get
the Queen's off the board and my king
will be fine here I think I should still
look to force White's hand in this
capture though and I think my rook will
be fine on a eight is there some other
idea I could come up with here
Queen a six a four I think it's hitting
if I do night c4 I might be able to make
use of this Kings position somehow with
an in-between night mouth Queen a six
and night c4
maybe I should avoid the Queen exchange
the only thing that's holding me back
from Queen a6 is this I a for idea but
is it really that strong Queen a six a
four night c4 get the Knights exchanged
take with the rook if Queen B five I
could play queen c6 I think I'm gonna
try for that there's no tricks happening
here yeah I don't see it so let's avoid
the Queen exchange and now look for this
so their King can't feel so comfortable
now at least I kind of piqued his head
out some alright let's get rid of this
pesky night and I'm prepared to capture
with the rook yeah
Viroqua and then maybe I could play b5
Oh actually I could play b5 now they
don't have a four anymore mmm however
that earlier mentioned rooks breathing
down the e-file that's now in place
Knight takes hero takes on e6 starting
to worry me some let's make sure that
night is long gone and maybe now finally
I can look forward to playing b5 maybe
yeah let's do it
b5
it is I only took 25 moves to get that
minority attack rolling I could threaten
a queen a four move maybe doubled a
pawns aren't so bad actually
without the Knights on board okay I
think I might go for that or no trouble
just centralized yeah let's go here if
they don't have some attack against my
king I'm going to get some target a 5 B
4 so they need to act fast
f4 isn't working because of this
although maybe they're lining it up now
I think that's a slow move b4 okay I
think I just stopped the f4 move it's
like that maybe yeah a good idea to get
my Bishop off of this file maybe they do
upon sack there shouldn't be anything
against my King though no they don't
have much time let's just be on the safe
side at least now on this I could
consider this take I should watch my
time as well huh take with the rook I
still won't be foreign let's stop this
break first
okay finally I'm going to have something
to bite out and they just what do they
just do let's go here keep this tension
okay - okay I could win this pawn next
or this one so I'm getting a pawn
finally well I got to go faster thinking
I have all day I don't have all day
stop that pawn from moving first and
foremost get to the C file if allowed
now let's at least double rook b3 next
they're giving me that pawn I'm up to
pawns and their King is cut off
prove my king I feel like I need some
time gainers now I could play my king
here keep my rook right there right here
hmm
let's keep their king cut off I have to
passed pawns now all right let's grab
that guy keep pushing
so g3 is going to drop now they might be
close to resigning let's just mop up the
pawns give a check here everything is
glued together
and then get their last pawn no steel
mating ideas I could just keep pushing I
wouldn't wanted to push there all right
they resigned hmm I think they needed to
get hot sir 8000 I think it became quite
critical for them let me go into the
analysis I felt like it once it excuse
me once it got too simplified when it
was just the major piece sending in the
bishops like right around here see this
this position right around here if white
doesn't have something against Mike King
this slow this minority attack that I've
been that I had in mind for the duration
of the game it once it hits a target is
created and then there's no time
for why to try and attack my king
there's a certain responsibility that
White has to defend something on their
Queen side which distracts them from
attacking my own King so if there isn't
something swift here's what I'm getting
at for white against my own king they're
in some trouble I
Wow III think I think an improvement at
this point for white is to maybe
challenge my queen they for nope and
drop their queen what I meant to say is
first this exchange and then a four hang
out here and then then it's a different
story you know like this night could
return here he's a great piece I would
I'd see this as equal let me throw the
evaluation on I see this is pretty much
a dead equal position and we both have
really good pieces neither of us has mmm
a structural deficiency what am I gonna
do attack be to know I got the night
here so hmm it's tough to see how to
make progress here I could try for this
but you know for as long as they keep
the rook here I have to worry as soon as
I hit with b5 they take I take and then
is this rook invasion gonna hurt me in
some way and this is this would be a be
a lot more resistance in that position
with the Queen exchange and then playing
a form
so how did we get how did we get there
yeah the bishop move isn't best you put
on the arrows right away I imagine that
this is holding as within wow I was
gonna say half pound I'm thinking more
like point three the whole way and I
think for most of it it's white who has
a slight advantage until it got really
simplified then this minority attack
showed itself to be a a big factor let's
see what uh it's reading here you know
okay well I'm off
it's just dead equal for a great while
so after Knight a5 the Bishop check is
where there's now nothing here so it's
only ever some slight advantage for
white but after Bishop to b5 there's
really no worry my concern was this
check and this is what I was voicing in
the game this line here where if I try
to get the light square Bishop solve
with Queen b6 I believe that this is a
move and it is stopping Bishop to b5
preventing the bad bishop for good
Bishop exchange I pointed out this move
but it's not really amounting to
anything I just have to return in what
have I accomplished nothing
yeah so this is a direction that white
could have gone in in other words to
keep the light square Bishop son board
keep the better of the two bishops on
the board to insert the check on a4
instead of Bishop here okay
we had the bishop check queen a4 was
better they took I don't know how much
better I think during the game I was
voicing I would consider a6
there's
thing wrong with that I have to take
with the night in this case my queen as
a responsibility it's just an even game
night here okay I have b5 I think d2
Bishop here just everything is quite
natural huh all these moves flight
square it's holding is even b5 although
you know I like I like my position here
because I have a slow plan where once it
hits it again the minority attack
there'll be a weakness and the Queen
side when it once it comes through so
hmm yeah I think that this is the better
line Queen a for Bishop back Queen c2
not allowing the light squared Bishop
steuby exchanged like really can't hold
first too much with LightScribe bishops
off five all right a4 I had some concern
over the over this yeah I guess I can't
take on d4 because of Queen to be - or
rook to be one no it's not working as
well no this is what I was pointing out
during the game oh man really rook b3
what a cool move that is huh
that's a good way to lose the Queen
actually you just can't take right away
what am I talking about rook to be three
nights pinned but bishop takes b4 as
tempting as it is rugby one I was only
thinking about getting the Queen off of
the C file off of this pin and
delivering a pin
so if b4 is played
I can't it's not best to take the pawn
but instead night h5 o or that move yeah
the downside here for white is that if
they don't have something something good
I mean there's this pond here that's a
forever target as soon as this night
moves and the baby sits c34 forever okay
they didn't go with B for a for they
just played the solid stuff developing
developing preparing to castle
let's see four computer points this out
but I'm just not a fan of it I want to
keep this open this open C file and
still look for the minority attack they
deform if I play this I have to play
Queen a for now this is running into
these tricks hitting the rook hitting
the Queen defending the bishop so I'd
have to do this in this is the main
reason I wasn't so much a fan of this C
it's fine with it
evaluation but I didn't like I'm even
threatening this stuff to break up the
structure if they stop this by playing a
three then this one pawn restricts too
and I guess I could still fight for
something I'd really like to have my
knight on c4 at this stage pinpointing
the base point B to white on the other
hand can reroute their knight on d4
which would uh at least stop major piece
pressure from pointing at B to a very
positional game all the way through
really going b5 and I gets a kick Queen
b3 good move okay it likes to move I
played ears securing d7 anticipating a
queen exchange rook e1 one move earlier
it's suggesting Queen a6 but I went with
her flight square and it wants to take
the Queen here they played King f2 and
now I went with Queen a6
the computer wants to just return at the
king uh-oh maybe the Queen's aren't
going to be exchanged I better run back
and now wants to go with the a4 yeah on
a four this was my idea takes takes with
the rook and on Queen B five to play
Queen here even I pointed out the
minority attack a six B 5 B for inducing
a Queen side weakness the only other
thing I could look into is having the
better Bishop the pawn on d4 is
potentially a target for this guy
White's Bishop on the other hand doesn't
have any prospects there's no black pawn
that is fixed on a dark square for him
to access for him to target but these
are their small points is it really
anything substantial I don't know that
it would really add up to so much but
instead of king f2 it likes this idea of
takes and then a4 I'm thinking I don't
see anything wrong with a 4 and then
they could play here and this is this is
what I thought I mean just really even
tough to get this in if I'm playing a6
there's even this may be tough to make
headway for sure much more difficult
struggle so I kept the Queen's on the
board for just a little bit there's now
starts to be a slight pull here for
black b5 gets in Queen a 6 a v g6 I
could go
in 4b 4 but just want to get out of any
potential tactics on the e-file and this
is really just collapsing here I don't
know how much it matters but I've been
pointing out what it is I want to do on
the queenside
at this point I mean it's really
simplified for white this is a direction
they should look to go in the g4 and f5
so that the rooks finally have a say in
the position for as long as they're
biting at a pond here who has pond
support they're really they really don't
have an influence in the game so I just
want to take a step out or I don't want
to invest one tempo here to stop g4 they
can't stop v4 that'll hit next move but
I could at least delay this g4 f5 idea
for a little bit they have to go about
it like they did with G 3 H 3 g4 they're
playing h3 I could play h4 in this case
this is a fine pond to have fixed on a
dark square because it Reed does what it
restricts to white pawns and there will
never be a pawn a white pawn getting to
g4 and so what that means is that
there's no f5 break that will translate
into rook activity along the e-file so
it has to come at a snail's pace so this
is a worthwhile tempo as my it's the
short short summary g3 I'm just hitting
much faster close to a pawn advantage
and now it's just spoiled it's it's a
very difficult road ahead no doubt
they're tethered to the defense of a C
pawn right there ok one
and oftentimes this is getting a little
bit I'm sure that there's many Mo's but
I think most accurate is to keep this
tension and look to apply pressure to
both B 2 and C 3 at the same time maybe
I capture maybe I push maybe I do
neither and keep like guessing in such a
in such a position where there is this
tension between the B and C pawns I'm
never really fearing as black white
taking away from the center because that
would weaken d4 and that will surely
drop so I think I do best to simply keep
the tension in other words keep these
options available to me and it opens up
when I want to open up and I keep like
guessing sir okay yeah and you know it's
just gone from here - - yeah I don't
think that there was anything missed
slowly improve the King position get
these past ponds rolling keep the king
cut off there's no reason to move that
rook off of the second rank unless
you're going to win a pond and yeah that
was that okay interesting game
positional one for sure but yeah once
that v5v for break was in there Queen's
are off the board white had a difficult
task at hand okay
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback in the comment section below to
this video and I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you